the US Senate is about to put a
president who was running for
re-election on trial the Senate meets
later today to establish the rules for
its impeachment trial while President
Trump highlights his accomplishments at
a meeting of rural leaders in Davos
Switzerland more than 4,000 miles away
senators will debate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell strategy for the
proceedings it offers each side 24 hours
to present evidence for and against
removing the president from office
Democrats complain there is still no
plan to call witnesses to testify chip
Reid is on Capitol Hill for us but first
we're gonna go to Paula Reed at the
World Economic Forum in Davos where the
president arrived earlier this morning
and recently took the stage so Paula
good morning what's the president saying
out there good morning Tony just moments
ago the president arrived here in Davos
where he sounded off on the Senate in
Pietschmann trial that gets underway
later today the other is just a hoax
it's the witch hunt that's been going on
for years and it's frankly it's
disgraceful but after that impromptu
statement the president gave a speech
touting his economic record now this is
an event about collaboration and unity
but President Trump campaigned against
the global elite and he seized on this
opportunity to highlight the current US
economy and his recent trade deals with
Mexico Canada and China the test for the
president this week is whether he can
stay focused on that positive economic
message and not on his frustrations with
the impeachment process back home now as
the Senate trial gets underway here in
Switzerland the president will be
sitting down to dinner with global CEOs
and CBS News has learned that while he
may not be able to watch the proceedings
he will be receiving briefings from his
advisors throughout the night now
yesterday the president's legal team
provided the first full comprehensive
look at their defense while they do not
deny the facts that were presented in
the house they accused Democrats of a
quote perversion of the Constitution
they argue that both articles abuse of
power and obstruction of Congress are
not impeachable and fed offenses because
they are not crimes but that's a theory
that has been debunked by many
constitutional scholars for just a
moment ago Tony I got a text from one of
the president's attorneys he
they feel great and they are ready to
defend the president Paulo climate and
climate change was also a big topic at
today's forum Greta toon burg the young
climate activist is out there and the
president had an announcement on the
subject of climate change what did he
have to say that's right the focus here
is on climate change the president is
sharing top billing with toon burg and
the person who was asked about climate
change when he first arrived here and
even though he has worked to rollback a
lot of environmental protections he told
folks that he said the environment is to
me very important and he also announced
the US will sign on to an international
initiative to plant 1 trillion trees but
the biggest meeting on the President's
agenda while he is here is a one-on-one
meeting tomorrow with the president of
Iraq this will be his first one-on-one
meeting with a leader of Iraq since
tensions flared with Iran this is an
opportunity for the president to focus
on statecraft
in contrast to all the partisan
proceedings back home Tony all right
Paula Reid in Davos for us Paula thank
you very much
you